what's up guys
bang bang we're back
it's lunch money time while wall street
is trying to get rich
the rest of us are just trying to get
our lunch money right i'm here
with paulina our new studio is a little
cold
so she has goosebumps running up and
down her arms it's really cold in here
i thought it was because she was so
nervous to be
around me but i guess not
don't forget that lunch money is now
sponsored by blockfi blockbuy has three
products you can buy and sell crypto on
a crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and take out a us dollar alone
or you can earn interest in their
interest bearing account they're also
coming out with the credit card go sign
up at blockfy.com
pomp that's right blockfy.com pomp
let's get into it why do you sound like
that um guys
we're back why do you say guys after
guys and gals uh we are back
after a hiatus during which
i got busy he got busy and then he
annoyed me and then i got busy and then
my family's it was like a whole whole
thing but we are back
hashtag woke okay ready
let's go jeff bezos will fly
on the first passenger space flight of
his company
blue origin in july so
blue origin plans to launch the mission
on july 20th
the 52nd anniversary of the apollo 11
moon
landing bezos's brother will join him
as will the winner of an auction being
held for one of the seats
this is wild we're sending billionaires
into space what do you think
i just want to know what that first call
is like what do you mean
yo bro want to go to space
or jeff do you really think you should
be the first one to go
and jeff's saying i've always wanted to
go to space
yeah but jeff you're worth billions of
dollars maybe you should stay here
in case something goes wrong and jeff's
saying no
if anyone's going it is me it's a big
difference between elon musk who has
sent many other human beings
on his spacecraft but has yet to take
the trip himself
one of the downsides is that
jeff bezos isn't really going to space
though from what i understand
supposedly it's a ride past the edge of
space
no no no to the edge of space the edge
no past the edge of space
and and the altitude is only 340 000
feet 340 000 feet we're not leaving
and going to the international space
station very different they're spending
a few minutes in zero gravity which i
think is pretty cool
a few minutes other people take a couple
days to get where they're going
why are you talking like that this is
how i talk now
this is not how you talk while i'm
recording
in these brand new nice microphones
never heard you talk what is the next
topic
stop him okay
this entire show is only going to be her
laughing
while i talk okay so
bezos said to see the earth from space
it changes you it's an adventure it's a
big deal for me how does he know he's
never
been to space but he's seen it on high
resolution
definition images this sounds like a
marketing message
marketing ploy all right the first stop
please
the president of el salvador says he's
submitting a bill
to make bitcoin legal tender what is a
legal tender first of all
bitcoin is inevitable oh okay it always
has been now we have nation states
who are saying we are going to embrace
bitcoin
by making it legal tender that means
that they can use it
as a nation-state recognized currency
the banks will take it the government
will accept it
the government will hold it in their
reserves and on their balance sheet
and my guess is that they will
slowly move from a us dollar-based
system to a
bitcoin based system this morning when
we woke up
most maybe not most many
people in the parliament of el salvador
now
have laser eyes along with the president
of el salvador
there is also a gentleman
from paraguay who has done
the infamous laser eyes donned down
what is how i say it and therefore that
shall be how it is said from now on
there is a double n in dawned but it's
okay we're just gonna
move past that some would say dawned is
spelled d-a-w-n
like dawn with an e.d
[Laughter]
e.d also if you've ever watched a
commercial okay
moving on okay cool el salvador happy
for you
the bill has yet to be passed it does
not yet pass that isn't important
it will pass okay because the president
of el salvador has the support
of the parliament all right next
facebook won't take a cut from creators
until the year 2023
facebook announced that um it will not
take a cut
until 2023 in an effort to draw more
influential social media users
onto its services because of you i am
now starting to talk like you and i
don't like it
specifically because of tim cook mark
zuckerberg has decreed
that he will not take from the creators
i apologize to our video editors who
have to
edit his sound levels right now
specifically the company will not take a
cut of any revenue generated by paid
online events
fan subscriptions badges and facebook's
upcoming independent news product
i feel like facebook has tried to do an
independent news product since like
2008 and it hasn't worked by the time
these products are launched it will only
be one year of not taking any fees
what does that mean we are in 2021
halfway through the year over the next
six months the products will be launched
and by the time they are all launched at
the end of 2021
they will still be saying by 2023 we
will start taking fees but do we think
that
this is an attempt to like they saw the
success of something like sub stack and
this is an attempt to
compete with it take away the people
maybe a little bit why but they're
probably going after apple more than sub
stack
oh you mean like in terms of podcasters
no in terms of being a platform
sub stack it is a platform
is a product that wants to be a platform
they probably will become
a platform but they are nowhere near as
platformy
as facebook has become
so at the end of the day what you must
know
is that facebook is going to launch
creator products
they are likely to have great
distribution
they are also likely to eventually take
money from this
and if you want to have platform risk
run like rats to facebook and sign up
for their products
i will not do that okay
logan paul the youtuber has gone the
distance with floyd
mayweather in an exhibition boxing match
that i went to last night and i thought
i was going to some sort of game but it
was a
boxing match
the article that she is reading has a
picture of
jake paul fighting ben askren oh my god
logan paul fighting floyd mayweather
espn got a little confused
espn do better not all paul
brothers look alike not all
hashtag not all paul brothers um
but this is no mere
excuse but the money grab exercise
some may even call it legal bank robbery
i think was the terminology that was
used
and they made bank
side note logan paul going eight rounds
with mayweather
pretty pretty impressive
but joe his brother who writes huddle up
read huddle up dot com or huddle up
sack dot com um showed me a video of
where
there is a situation there is a moment
where floyd it appears
knocked out logan paul
i almost said jake paul logan paul not
to be confused with jake paul
um and knocked him out and then like
held him
and then like they continued allegedly
allegedly
but i saw it no what you saw was two
people hugging
in a moment that looks like maybe there
was a knockout maybe there wasn't but
nobody will ever know
floyd mayweather is one of the best
entrepreneurs
of our generation floyd said when the
money comes in we'll see who's the real
winner
facts and at the end of the day i'm
going into the hall of fame for boxing
i have nothing to prove this dude's just
getting paid
so okay so mayweather is 44 years old
and and logan paul is 26. that
is wild because it looked like floyd was
like
edda's prime floyd is a grandfather
is he facts how do you know he has
grandkids
literally oh next
all right this is a man that
did something that few other men have
done
no he did not go to the moon no he did
not take a blue origin flight
he traveled cross country to mine
the diamonds for his girlfriend's
engagement ring
and he dug up a 2.2 carat
diamond to propose to her with
yeah a fool i tell you
why not somebody who takes his fate into
his own
hands literally and goes and mines the
diamond
that he will then propose with why
doesn't he go into the forest and kill
all of his food
then why doesn't he go and get the water
from the river and put it in a pail and
bring back the water and then
boil it maybe if he does maybe he does
then he would be an even bigger fool
yeah if we're going to live in a society
that puts at the altar of
consumption things like diamond rings
then benefit from the beauty of society
and simply go to the store and buy it
a man who minds his own diamonds is the
same man
who minds his own bitcoin
false false
damn that was quotable that was
tweetable somebody tweet that out
don't do it okay it's ask lunch money
time hashtag ask
lm in the comments below i hate that i
am talking like you right now stop me
daniel j asks three weeks ago
favorite gelato flavor have we not done
lunch money in three years yeah we
haven't
yeah exactly maybe next streak will go
for four weeks
we will not favorite gelato flavor
you know what a lockout is i'm about to
have a lock out of this show i
personally
don't like ice cream as many of you know
gelato is not ice cream i know but
gelato's like
i do like frozen yogurt though which is
really interesting gelato
it's like a little too sweet and like
icy for me
you know what i mean like just so
everyone knows what it's like to be
married to polina that was a great
example what is your favorite gelato
flavor
she hasn't answered and she's told you
nine facts
and three stories and still
no answer i would say lemon is that a
flavor
i think it is she also is a
serial killer it sounds like lemon okay
first of all you like grape
things he likes grape flavored things
who likes grape flavored things
not normal everyone knows purple is the
best gatorade flavor
like no one knows that zero people know
that
you drink the dehydrated pea looking
gatorade the yellow
uh that is false i don't drink any
gatorade
all right go on go on so what is your
favorite flavor
it's personal i don't want to talk about
it what it's like to be married to
anthony ladies and gentlemen
he won't answer your questions which you
may have many of
it's personal i don't want to talk about
all right
moving on thank you guys for watching we
are
back from the dead maybe from the
deceased maybe
yes we are i haven't had enough of a
negotiation with management what is my
compensation package
for spending my time if if he doesn't
negotiate properly with me on this show
i will do it alone
please leave a comment if you would like
to see her do this show by herself
you will get three stories five
unrelated fun facts
and all the things every show promised
delivered i would maybe that's what
we're gonna do is we're gonna turn this
into a solo-hosted show should i should
i be like um
um walter cronkite where i'm like this
is paulina's show no anthony hashtag no
anthony
and we'll spell paul in a p-a-u-l-y-n-a
all right guys that's it for today talk
to you in four weeks
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoying in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends